so I have a game for you today but
before we get there just to just to
tease all your characters a little bit
here can each of you tell me what you
think your character's greatest strength
is at the beginning of the season but
then also what's his greatest weakness
that could wind up you know doing you in
as you go on this treasure hunting
Adventure
well I think Oren's greatest weakness to
start out uh just I think you see it in
at the end of the first episode I mean
he's he just doesn't he's not thinking
straight right he's like oh my God
Snickers this is amazing let's do it not
even gonna think about why it's on a
shipping boat it's like it doesn't make
any sense but um I think a really great
strength that he has is
you know
motivating the group in a way that's
that's very fun and exciting and he he
he pumps Jess up in in second episode to
like really continue this this hunt and
uh yeah it's very fun to
to play kind of like the wild card I
think having uh sneakers and pizzas a
weakness is very very respectable yeah
yeah no yeah it's good uh I think with
Liam
um you know I think his his weakness
would be his uh his Lone Wolf aspect I I
think I think he he's uh he's a skeptic
and and that has made him jaded from
groups and and treasurements and stuff
and I think that's his weakness I think
his power though is that nothing scares
him is that is that once he is set on
something I do think that's a strength
of his he'll go for it he does not care
what the uh what the costs are yeah
yeah it's hot because I I feel like
Ethan just has so much growth from being
just you know he's a rule follower he's
a by the book kind of guy he's very
hesitant when it comes to danger or
anything that that involves risk and he
sort of like has to kind of like let go
of that but you know uh if we were to
flip it if we would flip the question
his he's he's always thinking outside
the box he's not just going for the
first thing that's in front of us he's
always thinking about what's happening
around the group and I think that
he he sort of overthinks but in the in
later episodes it's sort of it helps
protect the group yeah the hunt I feel
for you all dancing around spoilers this
whole day
very good job at it all right it's time
for my game now and I'm willing to bet
you're not gonna hear anything like this
game today so I love slasher movie so
what I want to do right now is I want to
put the Ensemble of this show in a
slasher movie so I'm gonna paint a
picture for you here you are on the set
filming an episode of National Treasure
and there all of a sudden is a mass
killer running around on set I'm gonna
give you some slasher movie tropes and
superlatives and I want you guys to tell
me which actor like the real person not
their character best suits this
description okay cool this is great okay
this is a dangerous game to play with a
group over Zoom but we're gonna make it
works let's do it let's do it all right
first one is who's most likely to not
realize that there's a slasher on set
and to go and investigate a strange
noise and be the first one to get killed
up for sure and sorry I would probably
like talk to the guy yeah before before
he killed me
um I'd be like hey yeah everything good
yeah just kill me it'd be fine though
that could be cute oh my gosh she just
volunteered for that yeah man
okay all right next one here who is the
most likely to sacrifice themselves for
the others oh man how do I feel like
it's you
I think it like I feel like you're
always the one it's like no no guys I'll
I'll go do it I'll go you guys hang here
like I'll park the car you guys get out
or you're always there like yeah I've
lived a full life yeah like I'm good to
go oh man I feel like ultimately the
answer to that question is is a
compliment so it's a good thing yeah
everyone spare game and we don't have to
kill them if you don't want them to know
oh no no we know yeah yeah this next
one's not so flattering who is the most
likely to trip and fall while running
from the killer so no that would be me
too
yeah
oh she does she does oh my gosh and
that's she's great I've never seen she
falls like a feather she is just she's
yeah
no clue what falling like a feather
means but now she's just graceful I
don't know yeah she pulls very slowly
yeah yeah
all right here it is
who is the most likely to be the very
first person to figure everything out
and give the group a Fighting Chance of
surviving listen yeah that's that for
sure all right here's one of my favorite
ones who is the most likely to just give
up at the start basically say like F
this it's too scary I'm out of here
no no I feel like Lyndon would cut well
no because we've talked no it would be
down for sure yeah Linda would be down
it wouldn't be you no you'd go in there
and fight I think maybe me
really I don't know you'd be like
seriously
[Laughter]
yeah that makes sense
the whole story here yeah yeah yeah now
I want to see this film it's it's hard
question because like we we're like go
getters we're all go get it don't ever
give up yeah if there was one I'd be
like I'm too old
Donald Glover I can't do this um we're
heading towards like the third act
Showdown right now okay most likely to
be the last one standing
yeah for sure
yeah yeah I think um oh yeah or I feel
like I'd be like Chris Hemsworth in like
uh uh cabin in the woods and you know
what I mean like think that I'm about to
make a difference and then okay most
likely to make you think that that
person is dead but then they're actually
alive and they come back at the last
possible second to say uh Lyndon
swimming for sure
no Lyndon actually would be
yeah see I feel like she's like done
that I feel like [ __ ] before yeah yeah
did I do it wrong like I can't die twice
can you only die once I mean oh no you
you said screw this and then came back
oh yes so that's a part of the whole
story yeah don't worry narratively this
all makes sense it's gonna be a great
movie one day or maybe you're a twin in
this film and like your twin is the one
and then see now we're just making rules
yeah just making up rules
of horror the more Bonkers and crazy it
gets sign me up I'm all for evil twin
movies well that obviously it has to be
an evil twin yeah they're gonna kick me
out of here in a minute one more
question that isn't a slasher question
for you obviously stealing is bad but
what is the one historical artifact that
might make you be willing to steal it oh
wow that's good
um probably the Mona Lisa and then I
would hang it like in my doorway when
people walk in and be like is that the
Mona Lisa yeah yeah yeah
um wow you have to go see Glass Onion
soon oh good good Mona Lisa elements in
that really oh I didn't even know that
yeah
uh this one's tough and I know you gotta
I know we're running low on time hey
I'll stay here as long as they'll let me
go on the longer you take is the longer
I'm allowed to stay here okay dang
probably the
um the Batmobile that Christian Road in
dock night I didn't know we could go
into like superheroes oh does it have to
can it be fictional I don't like asking
questions like this unless I have an
answer in my back pocket and I want a
uber too oh yeah I'm going I'm going to
icons of darkness in Hollywood and I'm
stealing the uh the Raptor hatchling and
the eggs
I love that
I don't know
um I he's actually never seen any movies
besides I joked real movies actually
sounds crazy
um
blow it up with something else for you
then tell me your favorite movie of all
time favorite movie about time uh either
Field of Dreams or Sandlot I love
baseball big baseball so maybe I would
choices yeah yeah maybe I would like
steal the bat that they use in children
um oh I'm gonna steal I'm gonna steal
the Babe Ruth ball from Sandlot
favorite movie of all time Iron Giant
super bad
yeah
a highly rewatchable movies your show is
highly rewatchable your cast industry is
spot on I love it congratulations guys
thank you so much nice to meet you